If I asked you to close your eyes
and imagine some wildlife
you would probably conjure up
an image similar to this…
Or even this…
The focus of your visualisation was
most likely the cute little fox,
rather than the Digitalis plant
or the Conium Maculatum plant.
Well, you’re not alone in this,
a 2016 study showed
that study participants
remember pictures of animals better
than they remember images of plants.
We've never been at this point
of disconnection and estrangement
from the natural world before.
We're surrounded by synthetic
and electronic entertainment
and we don't interact with plants
and nature as we once would have
had we been growing our own food
or hunting for our own food.
And this has resulted in what is
known as the nature deficit disorder,
where people don't recognise
plants at all
other than something that
they may consume for dinner.
The human eye sees green
a lot easier than any other colour
so it tends to group
green objects together
and fade them into the background.
And then there's the evolutionary
development within humans
that early humans
were threatened by animals
We also had to look out for movement,
for a fast moving lion
coming to eat us.
Therefore, the human eye picks up
movement and looks for movement.
So we often don't recognise plants
which are relatively unmoving.
Connecting with nature affects us
from our heads to our toes,
from micro bacteria in the soil,
which studies show can
enhance wellbeing,
to petrichor, the smell of the earth
after it's rained,
to the sound of birdsong,
which has been found to decrease
the stress hormone cortisol.
I realised I was disconnected
from the natural world
about eight years ago
during a period of recovery from
depression and addiction issues.
I found myself drawn to walking daily
on Walthamstow marshes.
And the experience of being in nature
and walking on the marshes
became as important
and as therapeutic
as the medication, the psychotherapy
and the support of friends
and family.
Those who have less access
to outdoor space,
and two and a half million
people in Britain
don't live within easy, 10 minute
walking distance of a green space ,
have fewer opportunities
to decrease their stress
through contact and connection
with the natural world.
Every year, more plant species
go extinct than animal species.
And in fact, CITES,
which is the Convention
on International Trade
in Endangered Wild Species,
that's fauna and flora,
has 30,000 plant species listed
compared to the 5,000 animal species
which are in danger of extinction
from legal and illegal trade.
Plants and fungi are the foundation
on which humans and
animals really depend.
And yet they're not recognised
and they are the underdogs.
They just keep toiling away
and keeping us alive.
You don't need anything
to go out in nature.
You just need to find something
that you're interested or curious in.
I love insects and lichen and moss.
I'm always looking around for
different species I can find
and patterns and shapes.
So I'd say just find something that
makes you feel wonder and awe
and say, "Wow," and just continue
your lines of curiosity.
Plants are essential to us.
They're not just a green background
or something for us
or animals to eat.
They are significant in our survival
as a species and as a planet.